john me convidaram aqui para que eu
falasse sobre fotografia mas eu quero
mesmo é falar sobre outras coisas
quando fazia faculdade de design eu
queria salvar o mundo e eu acreditava
reúne-se hoje o tento me salvar e já
está bem difícil
eu adoro design mas com o tempo eu
percebi que eu era boa mesmo em dar aula
então é professora e entre algumas
disciplinas
recebi como um presente a fotografia e
percebi que os meus alunos ele não se
bastavam apenas com o que estava nos
livros
eles precisavam também aprender o novo
olhar e ainda mais na fotografia eles
precisavam acessar a alma
isso é uma tarefa muito difícil se
conectar com o outro porque antes a
gente tem que conectar com nós mesmos
160 conectada comigo e com fotografia
o que eu gostava mesmo de fotografar era
arquitetura e paisagem
afinal elas não se mexem nem ficam
falando igual gente é muito mais fácil
não gostava de fotografar pessoas
isso se dava muito porque quando eu vi
as minhas fotos quando as pessoas me
fotografavam eu olhava aquela imagem e
não me reconhecia o tiago que eu via meu
corpo principalmente eu odiava tudo
aquilo só que com o tempo a gente fica
meio cansado disso então comecei a
buscar o autoconhecimento e aumentar
minhas práticas fotográficas para
melhorar a minha aula por conta disso eu
comecei a meditar e aí eu fui para a
índia na índia eu aprendi muita coisa
inclusive fotografar e uma das
experiências marcantes foi quando eu
estava observando o menino de mais ou
menos uns seis anos
ele estava todo sujo começou a pedir
esmola para várias pessoas e chegou até
mim infelizmente não tinha nada dar a
ele apesar de dar o mundo inteiro
garota e ele apontou para a minha câmera
como um gesto que quisesse que o
fotografasse entrou em quadra o menino e
apertar o botão eu encharquei minha
câmera com lágrimas
eu aprendi muita coisa naquele momento e
aí eu me tornei fotógrafa e nesse
momento eu descobri o que era acessar a
alma nesse exato momento eu comecei a
descobrir como que era fotografar as
pessoas também daqui que é um pouco
diferente de fotografar os indianos
eu vou mostrar pra vocês como é que a
gente fotografa mais ou menos me dêem
licença aqui pode fotografar aqui vocês
empregada microfone vai ficar ruim a
gente tem aqui fotografá lá no fundo no
fundo vai muito bem obrigado
agora já tenho um falso eficiente
primeiro instagram minha mãe vai saber
que houve um teste importante como é que
foi fotografada bem o que acontece
quando milhão a câmera pra gente a gente
já fica né haja naturalmente eu faço
igual tá aqui de natural não reinado né
e aí os indianos eles são muito naturais
eles são muito verdadeiras e eu
precisava também verificar como que era
fotografar aqui deixar com que as
pessoas ficassem também assim naturais
por conta disso algumas mulheres
começaram a pedirem para serem
fotografadas por mim e foi aí que surgiu
o projeto do corpo movimento
essas mulheres elas se sentiam muito
desconfortáveis no início
isso se dava principalmente por conta da
aceitação do seu próprio corpo e eu
entendia muito no início da minha vida
adulta eu tive obesidade passei por
várias dificuldades e preconceitos
eu odiava meu corpo eu tinha crises de
ansiedade
começava a me apertar toda querer eu
tinha vontade de me mutilar na verdade
eu ficava toda roxa
só que tem uma hora que isso cansa e
muito
nós mulheres somos cobrados o tempo todo
em relação à nossa aparência física eo
nosso comportamento social
mas a gente está cansado disso mas eu
acho que essas mulheres elas estão
mudando e elas foram loucas o suficiente
para encarar esse processo comigo e eu
aprendo muito com elas a gente cria uma
enorme empatia o melhor a gente cria a
cura e elas são fundamentais para esse
processo
quando elas vêm até mim a gente tem uma
grande conversa
muitas vezes a gente cria uma dança
entre nós mesmos e elas passam a
celebrar seus corpos
elas têm bastante lembrança memórias e
isso faz elas acessar em quem elas
realmente são
e aí eu falo pra elas imagina quantas
histórias carregam a cada célula do seu
corpo até aqui o seu corpo é a única
coisa que você tem de fato podem tirar a
sua casa seu emprego tudo mas se tirar
em seu corpo o que acontece então eu
convido vocês assim como eu convidei
essas mulheres para fazerem do seu corpo
o melhor lugar para se está me interessa
como você
o importante é você se sentir bem do
jeito que é
seu corpo é a sua propriedade então tony
ele consciente movimento em si e traga
ele até você e tudo bem a gente não
conseguir salvar o mundo essas fotos
estão aí pra lembrar que a gente
realmente é obrigada
[Aplausos]